on Wednesday night Milo you innopolis
stop by University of California at
Berkeley to do his schtick leftist
protesters joined by a large contingent
of anarchist rioters promptly gave him
everything he could ever hope for a riot
complete with violent destruction of
property large objects set on fire and
the innopolis supporters beaten in the
streets it was a vicious and disgusting
display of just how fascist many on the
campus left to become a few thoughts
first the campus left has been engaging
in the sort of fascism for at least a
year not every campus leftist group
engages in this sort of violence I spoke
at Berkeley last year no problem but a
shocking number of campuses have
experienced this sort of fascist
anti-free speech garbage the innopolis
has been at the receiving end of these
sorts of receptions at campuses dotting
the country and the riots aren't really
about you na police they're about the
very concept of allowing someone on
campus who the left considers radical
last February I was met with a near riot
at Cal State Los Angeles at Penn State
students tried to break through locked
doors to disrupt one of my speeches I
was banned from DePaul in the aftermath
of a student disruption against the
innopolis and told that I would be
arrested if I set foot on campus Jason
Riley of the Wall Street Journal was
disinvited by Virginia Tech before
finally being allowed on campus so this
stuff is happening all the time the
academic left second of all has prepared
the way for a lot of this campus fascism
why is all this happening right now well
because the campus left has built up a
pseudo intellectual bulwark around such
fascism they've told students they
deserve safe spaces areas in which their
ideas are not challenged in any way they
forwarded the culture of
microaggressions which urges students to
see any speech they find offensive as a
form of aggression to be countered by
other aggression here's NYU professor
Jonathan height on the phenomenon he
says the recent collegiate trend of
uncovering allegedly racist sexist
classist or otherwise discriminatory
microaggressions doesn't incidentally
teach students to focus on small or
accidental slights
its purpose is to get students to focus
on them and then real able the people
who have made such remarks as aggressors
as a professor at Cal State LA posted on
his door before my speech there last
year quote the best response to micro
aggression is macro aggression this line
of thought actually encourages evil as
Professor Roy Baumeister writes an evil
inside human violence and cruelty
hypersensitive people who often think
their pride is assaulted are potentially
dangerous even when a neutral observer
would conclude no serious provocation
occurred it is still important to
recognize that in the perpetrator
he or she was merely responding to an
attack colleges churn out and reward
these oversensitive people third riding
against speakers you consider radical it
helps those speakers you idiots
okay Annapolis his shtick it relies on
opposition the clips from his features
are all about triggering members of the
campus left which by the way is the
easiest thing in the world to do he
relishes this publicity like or dislike
Milo and I am certainly no fan if you
know anything that I've said about him
his provocateur stick only works if he
provokes a response way worse than that
which he's engaged in when the left
shuts down his speeches when they riot
when they engage in actual violence when
they pepper spray those who come to hear
him and hit them with metal poles all
they're doing is legitimizing the
innopolis in the public eye and making
him the victim and selling him lots of
books and making him lots of money
President Trump has weighed in via
Twitter he says that he will withdraw
federal funds from UC Berkeley if they
can't maintain free speech principles
that's actually appropriate spray
painting at killed Trump on walls
smashing ATMs assaulting people that is
not appropriate behavior in any
civilized society and for those who are
doing the spray-painting and the
smashing and the assaulting to proclaim
that they're anti-fascist is patently
insane forget Ian appleís the issue is
the left and they are out of control i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
okay tons to get to today in just a few
minutes we're gonna be having on former
assembly person from the state of
California
Mike Gatto he and I got into a Twitter
spat a few weeks ago I'm gonna have it
on to discuss that to talk capitalism
owes Berkeley good guy and we'll be
having around in just a couple of
minutes we're also gonna be talking more
about what happened in Berkeley and what
that means plus Donald Trump was at the
National Prayer Breakfast so what better
time to talk about Arnold Schwarzenegger
ratings on The Apprentice
yes really this is the world in which we
now live we'll get to all of that but
first we have to say thank you to our
advertisers over at lyft so if you are
somebody in need of a ride and you want
a safe ride a clean ride then you need
to use lyft my wife uses it all the time
she's a doctor that means that she's
coming home at all hours of the evening
last night she was coming home midnight
that means sometimes she's too tired to
drive after having helped birth babies
for the last 12 hours and so she uses
lyft and if she trusts lyft if I trust
lyft you should trust lift - the reason
is because all of their drivers are
fully vetted through a ten-point safety
standard including criminal background
check and DMV background check you're
gonna get around quickly and safely all
the lyft drivers are rated after every
ride so only the best stick around
you're not gonna get some creeper and an
old beat-up van a rape van picking you
up that's not how lyft works it's
actually gonna be somebody a nice person
in a decent car picking you up you can
tip in the app as well which means leads
to happier drivers means the drivers are
going to be more friendly to you and
thanks to lifts you never have to worry
about drunk driving or about driving
tired or about driving unsafe or
honestly even about owning a car if you
look close to work sometimes it's
cheaper to actually just use lyft
everywhere than it is to own a car
itself right now lyft is offering our
listeners a special deal you get three
free rides right now up to ten bucks
each so thirty dollar value when you
enter promo code Shapiro's so check that
out
lyft comm promo code Shapiro and it's
lyft download the free lyft app and use
the promo code Shapiro in the payment
section and you get that $30 off again
they're the people that I trust they're
the people and my wife trust and most
importantly they're the people I trust
with my wife safety so if I trust them
with that then you should trust lyft as
well they are the best in the business
okay alright so here we are
another day another violent outburst and
this is becoming more and more common
across the country as I say I've been in
the middle of these things actually half
our staff has been in the middle of
these things a lot of our
staff was there at Cal State Los Angeles
when there was a near riot last year
when I spoke at Cal State LA and the
question is what's driving this because
the truth is the vast majority of people
who are showing up to protest these
things have never heard of Milo they've
never actually seen anything Milo's done
or seen anything that I've done or read
anything that they've done they've sort
of read headlines from salon or slate
and that's about it
they don't actually do their research if
you actually actually wanted to stop
Milo the easiest way to do it be to
ignore him Milo is sort of like the
doomsday monster the more electricity
you shoot at him the more he absorbs it
and expands if you actually ignored Milo
he'd probably go away but the fact is
that the left can't ignore Milo because
they have decided that in the name of
their safe spaces everyone they disagree
with must be Ben so you have the mayor
of Berkeley coming out beforehand saying
that hate speech is not welcome in in
his City and that marginalized groups
being attacked by people like yin
appleís that's something that he doesn't
that he's not good with the only
marginalized group in Berkeley are the
people that the mayor doesn't like okay
Berkeley is a haven for a lot of folks I
mean there are a lot of people from a
lot of different political Isles it's
obviously left but I mean that is the
place where you let your freak flag fry
for a flyer I mean that's it that's
basically their motto so the idea that
you know there's people coming in who
are gonna disagree with that and then
they have to be shut out that sort of
has bled down unfortunately it's it's
blood it's now coming from the top so I
think that the election of Trump has
made the left in many ways fully insane
to the point where civilized behavior is
becoming less and less common this of
course does not apply to everybody who's
a liberal it doesn't apply to every
Democrat but there is the strong string
that's building up in the more extreme
circles that say that violence is okay
what they say is somebody's a Nazi
violence against Nazis is okay therefore
I can attack X right so this is why the
other day there's a neo-nazi you know
he's a white nationalist is probably
fairer named Richard Spencer who's
punched in the head on the street while
he was doing an interview when so the
internet Letta the internet lit up with
is it okay to punch a Nazi and the
answer is no it's not okay to punch a
Nazi it isn't because by the same logic
you can punch a Nazi you should be able
to kill a Nazi right if you're violating
someone's bodily integrity on the basis
of their political viewpoint you are
doing something uncivilized and wrong
but there's an actual argument over can
you punch the Nazi okay so a lot of left
is great Richard Spencer got punched in
the face that's just terrific and then
they say well my low is Richard Spencer
and then they say well Trump is Richard
answer and they say well Shapiro is
Richard Spencer and pretty soon is bled
down to Mitch McConnell is Richard
Spencer anyone I disagree with his
Richard Spencer and Richard Spencer is
Hitler therefore I can use violence
against them Sarah Silverman tweeted
today that she wants basically a violent
uprising
she says fascists should get overthrown
well in will use the military to
overthrow wake up and join the
resistance all caps once the military is
with us fascists get overthrown Mad King
and his handlers go bye-bye an
articulate statement from one of the
world's most brilliant political
commentators Sarah Silverman yeah and
and she's not the only one who's saying
this sort of stuff unfortunately we
talked the other day about at the Screen
Actors Guild David Harper got a standing
ovation for saying that you were gonna
punch people that you disagree with Joy
Behar just yesterday she was she was on
the view and on the view Whoopi
Goldberg's already labeled Trump the
Taliban so here's Joy Behar on the view
saying the Democrats ought to bring a
rhetorical gun to the knife fight I
think their job is to look at what's
being brought to them that's how it
played out that you know the Democrats
always go to a gun fight with a knife
yeah let them go with the gun this time
yeah the people are the only ones who
suffer we need to keep moving forward it
will help you fight the fights that are
good like pick your battles if you
really don't like this candidate fight
against him okay so the point here is
not that she actually means pick up a
gun but this sort of violent rhetoric
has has become much much much more
common as I say that's not a good thing
once the violent rhetoric becomes more
common once you label your political
opponents the enemy to actually be hurt
and everything is on the table then that
means you're gonna get a lot more of
this sort of activity now I do want to
say one quick thing about the Berkeley
students not that my guess is that if
you look at the footage of these these
riots the rioters don't look like
Berkeley students they don't look like
kids who are lefties at Berkeley it
looks like those kids are standing
around then a bunch of anarchists came
in from Oakland or from or from Berkeley
or from San Francisco to make trouble
they look like WTO protesters from 1999
smashing windows and looting and and
doing this sort of stuff I don't want to
blame all Berkeley students for the
actions of a few but the problem is this
sort of mentality is spreading well
joining us now on the program I'm
pleased to welcome former assembly
person with state of California Mike
Kathy's Imus statewide candidate for
office soon if I'm not mistaken what are
you running for now
I cited yet I think politics is a little
bit up in the air right okay she's
running for governor so my dad oh is is
is a longtime assembly person from the
state of California he and I got into a
Twitter spat the other day and that's
why I'm having him on so I think a good
place to start is with what's happening
in Berkeley what do you make of the of
the hubbub of the chaos of what is a
riot that happened in Berkeley last
night well first of all I was in office
when you were at Cal State LA last
February and I want to apologize I want
to start by apologizing on behalf of the
state of California for what you went
through I appreciate it thank you I mean
nobody should ever when they're on a
publicly funded campus that is paid for
by taxpayer dollars have to have their
free speech quilt you could argue maybe
it's different on a private campus but
that was a public campus where people
sought to clamp down on your free speech
the state of California owes you an
apology too they sent that I can do it
for the on behalf of the whole state
okay I appreciate it and it's not your
job to do it on behalf of the whole
state obviously you didn't do it I only
like to put responsibility where it lies
but but I appreciate that so yeah I mean
I think that the first place to start is
that this is why I like having people
who disagree on the show I'm gonna start
doing this a lot more often now that we
can have guests and I think that that's
fun because it's fun to have the
discussion and it's really negative what
happened last night so what is so I
won't let's before we get to what we
were spouting over on the internet which
was which was a lot of fun now would I
do want to get to it cuz it's kind of a
kick i I want to ask you Assemblyman
gotta what do you make of how the hell
should the Democrats treat the accession
of President Trump so a lot of people
see me going kind of nuts over there
what do you think is the best way for
Democrats to deal with this because
obviously I think that the sort of
extreme rhetoric and tactics not sure
this is gonna be productive correct I
was talking to a veteran Democratic
Congress member from DC yesterday and he
said you know think about it everything
that Trump has done so far in office is
designed to appeal to rural Pennsylvania
and rural Michigan all the key areas of
the swing states that Democrats lost and
then by lighting cars on fire in
Berkeley I'm not sure that we're gonna
win those pots back well I appreciate
the honesty and I think the obviously I
think the Democratic Party could use
more people like you and positions of
power saying that because it seems like
the Democratic Party is moving in a more
extreme direction by embracing some of
the candidates they're talking about for
the DNC chairmanship there's that event
a couple of weeks ago where the DNC
chair candidates were saying things like
as white people we have to sit down and
shut up and and we have to we just have
to listen to black people it's my job to
shut out the other white people that
seem to me geared toward lending the
white middle-class voter in Michigan
Pennsylvania Ohio or Wisconsin so okay
so I want to talk a little bit about
your broader worldview because the
reason that we invite you on in the
first place is because we got into this
fight as I've referenced a couple of
times on Twitter and the reason that
that came up is because I wrote a piece
about one of the one of the things that
the talking point that folks on the Left
have been pushing for quite a while this
idea that the people at the very top of
the income spectrum have way more money
than everybody else the people who
earned the 1% owned as much wealth as
the rest of the world combined that the
top 60 people owned as much wealth as
3.5 billion people and basically I wrote
so what right the people at the top
unless they stole it from the people at
the bottom why is this a problem and I
talked specifically about Bill Gates
who's now about to become the world's
first trillionaire apparently and and I
said you know there there's hundreds of
thousands of people who have worked for
Microsoft they create a product that
millions of people buy and makes their
businesses better what what's the issue
here and you then proceeded to tweet
this so this is the tweet on feudalism
so your screen is a gross over someone
we're in person play this great is a
gross oversimplification to akin to
medieval mentality of kings and Nobles
protected us in battle
so nobility is awesome so maybe you'd
like to explain where that comes from
why do you think that and I asked you I
asked you so what makes Bill Gates a
medieval feudal lord well first of all I
never gain as many Twitter followers or
I never got my my my behind spanked as
much as when I did so your followers are
very very enthusiastic yeah but um but
the point I was trying to make is this
so I'm a traditionalist I believe it
round there's a Democratic
traditionalist I know that our founding
fathers believed in small everything
they believed in small government they
believed in small concentrations of
wealth they thought that if we had the
return of nobility in this country that
we'd be in a really bad place we looked
like those countries in Europe that
people had left we would have this great
concentration of power it would start to
seem like nobility and that's what that
reference was and I do believe that
there are times in history where the
wealthy have more and they start to look
like Russian oligarchs and nobody would
disagree that Russian oligarchs are kind
of like nobility they can control
government they have the power of life
and death in certain towns and in
certain provinces and
that's not good for our American Way
about well you agree on the idea that
Oleg Archy is bad obviously but I'm not
comparing Bill Gates to a Russian Oleg
I'm not saying abused to but but there
is a saying that all great fortunes come
from some crime and I don't think that's
that's true though unless you can
actually prove the crime it's a little
bit of a slander to suggest that that
people are engaged in crime just because
they're wealthy there's a lot of
companies that when they start out the
regulations are not quite there yet and
they act in a regulatory vacuum and in
many cases they're taking resources that
you could argue belong to society and
they are exploiting them to their well
unless you're talking about like people
actually going into the Commons and
drilling for oil in areas that's not
owned for example then you know what
resource do corporations like Google
exploit or corporations like Microsoft
exploit it seems to me that their
employees are some of the happiest
people on the planet seems to us that
you know you and I have great technology
because of companies like this and and
seeing wealth as in an indicator a red
flag for something criminal has occurred
number one sort of lets people who are
poor off the off the hook if they
actually commit crime and number two
says that wealthy people are actually
the ones who are criminals when it seems
to me that a lot of the people who are
wealthy are wealthy specifically because
they're engaging in lots of voluntary
mutual transactions which is the way our
economy works if it's not voluntary you
and I are on the same side right if
somebody's actually exploiting somebody
else we don't disagree but if somebody
is not exploiting somebody then what's
the problem so you and I are both
against the redistribution of wealth but
my point was there's many ways to
redistribute it so Rand Paul and Ron
Paul both have said to audit the Fed and
I've supported yeah I think the Federal
Reserve which is it's a quasi
governmental agency its appointed by the
president the governors are appointed by
the president I think that their
policies have favored those who own
locks lots of stocks and those who and
lots of property sorry I favor like like
the like the Paul's are of the returns
of the gold standard you know I think
the gold standard for a long time served
our country just fine I actually have a
return to the gold standard is well you
know it's it's real money and it's tied
to something that government can't
create so I you can demo credit or
understand
this is Eris a Democratic traditionalist
out there and I think I am one of them I
mean I think there's nothing wrong with
being a smaller government Democrat and
I think there's also nothing wrong with
saying that the federal reserve's
policies have benefited those who I'm
when you're lending money at next
nothing and you're inflating these
bubbles the people who tend to own those
resources benefit from it so and we're
in a weird way that's a redistribution
of wealth - no I totally agree it's a
redistribution of wealth by government
and as I say I'm very libertarian on a
lot of this stuff and that is keep the
government out unless somebody's rights
are actually being exploited now I don't
wanna hit you over the head with your
tweets but I'm gonna hit over the head
with your choice so here's saying
there's one more this is this is you
talking about inherited wealth and again
things get dicey on Twitter in a way
they don't when we speak to each other
face to face says I'm curious what the
great grand children of the wealthy
invented to wealthy invented to deserve
it a smarter Ben Franklin railed against
nobility so the implication here seems
to be that the founders were against
inherited wealth Benjamin Franklin did
speak openly about the estate tax he
likes the idea of an estate tax because
European nobility was not quite the same
thing as American capitalism producing
people who are wealthy
there's a merkin to a system in Europe
where the government actually gave
charters to specific friends if the
government actually looks a lot more
like what a presidents of both strikes
have been doing actually lately we're
you know it looks like the green jobs
program or like Trump giving favors to a
particular company which it looks like
corporatism that's what old-school
European nobility look like and in fact
Ben Franklin when it came to his own
distribution of wealth at his death Ben
Franklin actually handed virtually all
of his wealth to his children to give a
thousand pounds to the city of
Philadelphia a thousand pounds to the
city of Boston and that was it right so
it wasn't like he got reheat he
liquidated all his wealth and said kids
you're on your own right so are you
again are you in favor of the idea of a
high estate tax taking lots of money
away from people who have already been
taxed on that money because we don't
want their kids having it so so I do
take tend to take the Ben Franklin
proach Thomas Jefferson was more of an
extremist on the estate tax he didn't
think that people should inherit much at
all Ben Franklin actually wrote that he
thought that the average middle-class
person should be able to pass on their
home even to homes three homes to their
kids but he did think that there really
really big estates should suffer some
type of estate tax and I think the
middle class should not be subject to an
estate tax but I think the very very
very wealthy the high-end there should
be some estate taxes otherwise you just
run the risk of our society devolve into
a bunch of paris hilton's she's
beautiful she's talent
but you know it was like her
great-grandfather founded something
useful and she don't do much and that's
what that tweet was was relating to well
I mean listen I'm no Paris Hilton fan
but I also don't think that I have the
right to take away grandpa's wealth just
because I don't want Paris Hilton to be
doing Carl's jr. commercials yeah but
but but that is a little bit of
postmodern stuff that you might
criticize if the left was saying it
because because government does have the
right to draw lines when we elect the
government whether they're Democrats or
Republicans we are saying please draw
the lines I think an estate tax would be
much more fair than an income tax I I
think because you want to remove the
income tax if you're in favor of
removing the income tax in favor of a
small estate tax then maybe I'm with you
yeah our country survive for the first
hundred fifty years on primarily three
taxes there's a sin tax it was the
Whiskey ten right there there was a
state taxes and there were tariffs and I
think if we could come back to some sort
of system where weary looked at our tax
code and said hey this is more fair
we're going to break up large estates
we're going to tax sins and we're going
to rely on some sort of tariffs to
punitive to penalize the worst abusers
and of slave labor in third-world
countries I think that would be a better
system than what we have now okay that's
interesting because you know the look I
think it's immoral to tax people twice
so if you're gonna have an income tax
and then you're gonna steal money that
I've already paid taxes on one of my I
mean you have children and I assume yeah
I mean how many kids you have I have two
and a third on the way okay
congratulations that's exciting so I
have two hundred three and the end one
of the reasons that I work really hard
is because I would like to pass on lots
and lots of money to my children so
they're enough to work so hard which is
part and parcel of the American Dream is
not just I work hard I get ahead it's I
work hard I get ahead so my kids don't
have to work quite as hard to get ahead
and when it comes to inherited wealth I
think there's this this vast misnomer
that the people who are the wealthiest
in our society all of them inherited
their wealth and actually when you break
it down that's not really true like 35
fording to in 2012 there's the Forbes
400 and twelve thirty five percent of
the Forbes 400 was born poor or
middle-class 22% were born upper-middle
class that means 57% were born either
poor middle class or upper middle class
11.5% inherited more than a million
dollars seven percent inherited more
than 50 million so that would be Paris
Hilton and 21 percent inherit enough
money to just stay on the list right so
that tax the 7% I mean when I got the
tweets back from with with our exchange
from your followers I mean a lot of
people said hey I'm just a middle
sky do you want to take my wealth the
answer's no I do not want to take that
wealth I'm the same way I work very hard
that my children will have a better life
and by the way I am NOT a career
politician I I really have had jobs and
I have a job now and I'm working very
hard but um but I do think we do run
this risk of returning to this this era
of nobility if we don't break up the
vast vast fortunes it's that 7% or 6%
you talked about yes use me I don't
think those fortunes should be broken up
I think the key is to protect the system
itself said that those fortunes can't
impact government and that means having
a smaller government in total because
the problem is once you get to the point
where the government can confiscate a
state wealth you know that the
government is so corrupt that there
gonna be some estates that somehow
escape and there's gonna be some estates
they confiscate sales tax they
confiscate it income tax they confiscate
so many things we have to have tax we
have to pay for the crumbling roads in
LA that are never paved we have because
I made a lot of money well it's not
punishing you because you made a lot of
money what it's trying to sort of is
you're only hitting me if I'm really
really wealthy yeah but I mean that
listen that's that's how that's how a
lot of tax codes are I mean I know they
suck well they didn't they do but if you
think that the wealthy guy who buys a
Rolls Royce
he pays more in sales tax than then
someone like me who doesn't owner is a
choice to buy that car right I mean
right that's a little bit that's a
little bit different now you're talking
about you just look at the bottom line
and you say okay you made more than 7
million you made you know 2 million the
7 million Duyck maybe you cut it off at
a billion dollars but but the point is I
just think I'm a traditionalist and I
think our founding fathers believed in
this system which was yeah you know you
let the you let the person pass on three
four or five houses their kids that's
fine you let them pass on their cars and
their bank accounts but maybe the person
who starts to look like a Russian
oligarch cuz they've got so much power
and so much money we probably don't want
that in America and by the way this type
of this type of people ignoring this
politicians in power ignoring this for
so long is why Donald Trump won all
these Midwestern states is because he
actually talked to people and said look
I'm going to try to return good jobs to
do your class I think that's right I
think it's also I think it's ironic that
you say Donald Trump is an example of
that because Donald Trump is actually
part of that seven thank you so much for
stopping by it really is a pleasure to
have you and and it's always fun to have
a cordial conversation with somebody
with whom I disagree so thank you for
for the time and thanks for coming in
Assemblyman Mike gotta thank you and
walk out from he's gonna run for
governor even though he says he's just
considering it
sure that you keep an eye on that well
well we have to say thank you to another
one of our sponsors
these are sponsors over at CCO so if you
love comedy I mean if the political
system isn't enough comedy for you and
you just love comedy and you want more
of it see so is the place to be see so
is law is streaming content see so is
acclaims original series it's
hand-picked classics it's hours of
stand-up specials no commercials
completely ad free you get a month for
free right now when you go to see SOCOM
see so come and see SOCOM and you use a
promo code Shapiro so if you check that
out right now then you get at least one
month for four actually two months for
free now I guess so it's two months for
free with the promo code been at
checkout that see SOCOM promo code Ben
my wife and I've been watching one of
their shows called Harmon quest which is
really funny it's sort of it's sort of
making fun of the the Dungeons & Dragons
crowd and it's it's it's pretty funny so
she checked that out they have a lot of
original series they have a lot of old
content they have old episodes of The
Office from Britain which is really fun
to have a lot of British comedy they
have all of the SNL back from one SNL
was good and not just the Trump attack
vehicle check it out at sea SOCOM promo
code ben and it is fantastic as I say it
is it is normally 399 a month you get
the first two months for free you can
cancel at any time if you don't like it
so give it a try I promise you won't be
disappointed
okay so as you say the the situation in
Berkeley is really ugly I want to show
you some of the footage from Berkeley so
the butan so that folks know what we're
talking about last night
there's here's some of the the people
shooting off fireworks at public
buildings last night at Berkeley
edgy so edgy
and you can see it's it's black bloc
minutes they call themselves because
they wear all black and they're they're
basically terrorists and the police wear
the cops and all this wonder what are
the cops doing I have no idea this is
the experience that we had a Cal State
LA as well by the ways the cops were
basically told to stand down because
they didn't want to promote violence
didn't want to have a violent clash so
instead you let the the rioters run
roughshod there's more of this here as
I'm shooting off some flares
all righty so you can see it got really
really ugly last night and we'll talk a
little bit more about that plus we have
the mailbag coming up an order for you
to see that you have to go over to daily
wire calm right now become a subscriber
you can watch the rest live become part
of the mailbag we're gonna do live
mailbag questions today yeah it's very
exciting so we're gonna check that out
today go to daily wire comm eight
dollars a month we'll get you a
subscription eight dollars a month and
then if you get an annual subscription
then you get a free signed copy of my
book true allegiance that deal is ending
soon so check it out right now at daily
wire.com we are the most popular
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you